welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in at the ceremonial weigh-ins for ufc
paris things got heated between marvin
vittori and robert whittaker vittori
refused to shake hands with whitaker and
the pair shared some harsh words
i saw him being you want to be friendly
i'm going to crush him tomorrow
whitaker isn't the only one that marvin
vittori is getting hostile with at media
day victoria made disparaging comments
about fellow middleweight darren till
the pair have a history together going
back and forth on social media and
vittori told reporters that till is
delusional and that he believes he'll
never come back till shot back a fiery
response at vittori via espn's brett
akamoto i don't think i ever even called
out there until like he's actually
completely irrelevant at this point i
think in the division delusional also
marvin
listen you big stupid
i i wish you all the best this week in
your fight i hope you do really well
because you're a great fighter but let's
get on things sleep brother right
i'm 29 when i'm healthy it's just fight
fight fight that's all i'll be doing
nothing i think about more than just
fighting
so
what are you talking about mate
stop trying to put me down you big
stupid all
because we're gonna meet one day and i'm
gonna survive me fist through your face
ufc broadcaster laura sanko sat down
with thick boy fight news to give an
exclusive preview of ufc paris's main
event surreal gone vs tied to ivasa
senko pointed out the stylistic
differences between the two fighters and
where the winner fits in in a stagnant
heavyweight division
yeah gone versus tuivasa is i mean
that's interesting on so many different
levels because you've got the stylistic
match up you've got gone who is one of
the more technical strikers in the
entire division really does not move
like a heavy weight i mean he's one of
the few heavyweights who genuinely
doesn't move like a heavyweight and then
you've got tuivasa who super fast but
he's got more of that traditional heavy
hands i'm gonna go out there i'm gonna
bang it up but he started to incorporate
more of his wrestling so i mean i love
this fight for so many reasons the
stylistic matchup is one of them but
then just having
both of these guys young in this
division heavyweights heating up again
you got tom aspell i know he's out with
an injury but as soon as he gets back
you've got the
the specter of jon jones kind of hanging
in the wings
we'll see when and if he comes back
we're thinking maybe it's going to be a
december november time period so
heavyweights heavyweight is heating up
for sure but i think gone versus tuivasa
obviously super important fight for that
division and whoever gets the better
that one right at the top gain will be
giving tuivasa a nearly 20 pound weight
advantage when they step into the
octagon on saturday at the official
weigh-ins gain came in at 240c pounds
the exact same weight he fought his last
two fights at tai tuivasa tipped the
scales at
266 pounds the maximum for a non-title
heavyweight bout former ufc welterweight
and middleweight champion george st
pierre was on hand that media day for
ufc paris the french canadian fielded
questions from fans in both english and
french during a q a session when
prompted by a fan st pierre gave his top
7 fighters that helped shape the sport
humbly gsp did not include himself video
courtesy of mma junkie rice gracie
because he made stuff he did stuff in
the beginning that nobody
i've ever done i would have put i will
cheat because i have to put more than
four i would put
amanda dunes already even though she has
not retired yet because she's the best
female fighter that ever lives i believe
i would put
i would put khabib because he had a
perfect career undefeated incredible
i would put
conor mcgregor mcgregor also because he
brought the sport
to a different level
i will put jon jones and anderson silver
and timmy peters johnson because of
their performance
michael bisping took a look ahead at
next week's pay-per-view ufc 279 nate
diaz versus hamzat shimayev on his
youtube channel bisping talked about
diaz's massive underdog status which he
believes doesn't give diaz the credit he
deserves you can't count out nate diaz
let's be honest more than likely chemiev
is going to be a gigantic favorite in
this fight and i understand that but
nate diaz has been in there with some of
the best the reality is he's lost a lot
of fights the 13 losses it doesn't sound
good that is almost like getting to
journeyman status which sounds offensive
but i'm not the man's been in there with
the best of the best when you look at
the people that he's lost to they're all
champions they're all at the top of the
food chain if you're gonna beat nate
diaz you have to be special you can't be
some average guy some average joe some
guy that's okay that's had some success
you ain't gonna beat diaz like that diaz
comes in ridiculous shape every single
time he and his brother as we know
compete in a lot of triathlons and
things like that beautiful jiu jitsu if
it hits the ground always very very
dangerous and excellent boxing he knows
how to use his reach his range beautiful
hands not the most powerful puncher but
he can pack a punch you can never count
out nate diaz he is always in the fight
michael chandler is still looking to
fight conor mcgregor but is willing to
wait for the irishman to recover
chandler famously called out mcgregor
after brutally knocking out tony
ferguson at ufc 274 but recently told
mmafighting.com that mcgregor has earned
the right to a lengthy recovery you talk
about weidman you talk about conor you
talk about these real leg breaks you're
talking about cracking the bone in half
having your rods surgically inserted
into the bone you're talking about real
surgery stuff and obviously have i
called that conor do i want to fight
conor do i think that a fight with conor
would be the biggest fight you can make
in mma yes i do but the guy has earned
the right to sit out as long as he needs
to heal because the ufc is better when
conor's fighting and is in it and is
active so he needs to come back when he
is healed tyson fury ripped into unified
boxing heavyweight champion alexander
usyk on friday fury posted a minute long
rant calling out usyk and accusing him
of ducking the fight fury who has a
6-inch height advantage over usyk mocked
the ukrainian by calling him a
middleweight the gypsy king stated he'd
like to fight in december but is willing
to wait forever until usyk is ready usac
middleweight
you say you want the wbc
and it's held by gypsies it is held by
gypsies it's held by the gypsy king
and it's held tightly grasped tight on
all roads leads to a seven foot beam off
that will absolutely destroy you
middleweight
middleweight you will get smashed to
bits
you say you wanted to fight me after you
beat the bodybuilder called me out on
television and now you're being a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] boy running
hiding saying you've got injuries you
ain't got no injuries you've got a
sparring contest
get out fight december you let your
mouth go now let's back it up see if you
can back it up middleweight doesn't
matter if it's december
or april or august next year
the outcome will be the same i will
obliterate you i'm a 7 foot 20 stone
beam off and i will destroy you
middleweight find your balls come see me
[ __ ]
that wraps up another week here at thick
boy fight news heading into the weekend
with a laugh and enjoy some friday
funniest
[Music]
looking for more original mma content
check out the rest of thick boy youtube
exclusive interviews opinion and fight
analysis is available weekly on the shob
show food truck diaries and fight night
flashbacks subscribe so you don't miss
any of the action